it's Authority today our car expert in
his Petrie is driving a special model
one of just 50 ever built worldwide hers
is number 33
it's a t2 VW bus hang on a minute just
50 of false wagons most famous type 2
bus the classic camper van which sold
around the world
well this VW bus is an anniversary model
it was built in 2007 to celebrate the
Vans 50th year in production not in its
native Germany but in Brazil T twos went
out of production in most places way
back in 1979
getting into this one almost feels like
traveling back in time but Manson on
that nine Ynez says the t2 was built in
Germany until 1979 but it's not really a
vintage model because it continued to be
produced in Brazil until the end of 2013
over more than half a century close to
four million T Tunes were produced their
own model of products here's this VW bus
was also made in Brazil where the model
is known as the combi still it doesn't
look out of place on German roads yet
few Europeans would guess that this
old-fashioned looking vehicle is
actually a fairly new one
fregley inna says that compared to
today's cars that t2s technology is
pretty primitive while driving she finds
that the steering wheel feels very
spongy shifting distances are extremely
long
the manual transmission offers four
forward gears and one reverse gear but a
look at the commies interior is enough
to make a classic car buffs heart skip a
beat nothing here looks time-worn many
of the details here are now considered
classic the switches knobs and levers
have stood the test of time
the combi is still very much a part of
many Brazilians everyday lives
it's a fairly common sight on city
streets in Brazil
at meats here fans can see every kind of
VW bus imaginable Brazilians love their
copies
the VW bus still has many admirers in
Germany - they're drawn by the man's
versatility and reliability
the campervan also conjures up images of
adventure and road trips with friends
and no wonder as this version boasts
three rows of seats and room for nine
passengers
our menus it's often happiness as the
seats may look a little basic but
they're actually quite comfy and the
interior boasts poodles of space the
only thing she finds small is the trunk
that's a stereo phone when that's
examined that's meant it in his explains
that that's because the motor is housed
under it until 2005 comm bees had
air-cooled engines this 2007 model is
fitted with a water-cooled straight-4
engine
it takes 57 kilowatts out of 1.4 liters
of cubic capacity and that's the van
reach a top speed of 130 kilometers an
hour
oh my let it in it says that although
the VW bus looks old-fashioned in Brazil
it kept up with the times
VW fit the last colby's with a bivolo
engine so they could run on gas and
ethanol in December 2013 the last calm
Bea's rolled off the assembly line at
the VW plant near Sao Paolo even if its
engine was modern the rest of the
vehicles technology was decidedly retro
in spite of their best efforts the VW
engineers couldn't find a way to equip
the bus with airbags and abs to comply
with a new Brazilian law so after 56
years in production it was the end of
the line for the combi until then some
20,000 were built each year in Brazil
the very last VW bus made in Brazil
called the last edition number 1200 of
1200 found a home in Germany at
Volkswagen commercial vehicles workshop
in Hannover in Germany the VW bus is
already a classic and in Brazil people
will likely be tooling around income
bees for a long time to come
you